I've never gotten a call to be on Real
Housewives of Atlanta I have you have
you guys said no no go away which is
even like a cameo like you're gonna I
didn't want for candy one time okay well
this is the thing I don't play like that
like I don't - OH - the argument first
of all arguing nobody I don't care about
I care about you I'll take the time to
do this I don't know how to do that okay
so you've got I couldn't bail her out
because if I'll be right there with her
you know honestly like my mom even was
like she knows because I do really have
a temper in that area and it's not the
fact the part that bothers me is one
grown women kandi is pretty cool on
there but some of them it's not the fact
that you're throwing digs they try to
hurt somebody's the fact that you're
just being disrespectful just because
and in bullhorns of people's faces then
you want to call you know lawyers when
like you can't do disrespectful things
and think you're not gonna get hit or
something like it did that's not
realistic and I'm not like promoting
violence or any all those shows like
that welcome housewives
no matter New York and doesn't matter
where they are they're all acting the
same way and you know we said oh we have
a brand to protect
and there's me there's just no way so
you guys got the offers please be a cast
member on Atlanta yeah oh yeah but my
but my publicist every time she says I'm
just calling to let you know that they
call I already said no I was like okay
so they've a year after year they give
you an annual call it's so it's just
been twice for me but said you need to
say no in a way that lets them know that
I would never do I would never go on a
show like that how many that's cool for
something like that I'm gonna say I mean
yeah you know I just little knowing to
do that your brand it's not your vibe
it's not no it's just human all day like
I want to I want to argue that I don't
wanna hear you yeah okay you know I'm
trying to get past that that part of my
life is gone again this is why 20-plus
years
peace in my life and good things good
absolutely so I know on housewives but
yes on a new tour now we Flo Rida yeah
how did this tour come to be it's quite
a it's not a duo a quartet two female we
have toured in the States and overseas
so we thought about who would be perfect
with the energy because we all play high
energy yeah low rider was perfect
I just think M performed before it's
like you that mean gets the room going
cuz they're out yeah those shoulders and
so and have you guys performed with Flo
Rida before is it just that history no
this is this is new first time so we're
happy to have him on the road with us so
excited
[Music]